[Music]
my name is Jeremy can I'm gonna
introduce you guys to someone special
tonight this is my fiancee
Melissa go ahead and stand up baby come
on and off I know I'm taking I'm sorry
earlier this year we had some tough news
some really tough news can we do
something special for the most special
person in my life tonight can we pray
for her
[Applause]
[Music]
you heard tonight now we have an artist
he's had 32 number one state
4.5 million album sold
let's welcome Jeremy Kemp do believe
you're getting married yeah but we'll
see get better I don't know son you're
only 20 years old you just met this girl
I'm supposed to be with her I can't
explain it
I just know that
don't see I want you to know that
whatever this is then wherever it takes
us that I'm with you every step every
moment I'm with you
I'm so in
I will love you cherish you every moment
of every day I'll need the love of your
life and your biggest fan
[Applause]
this was my destiny stop you were the
strong one not me
all I have are questions what am I
supposed to do with that
[Music]
I keep thinking
one person's life is changed by what I
go through
they call them
I still believe
[Music]
[Music]